bonjour les enfants
nous allons découvrir ensemble les
secrets de fabrication du film niko le
petit renne
waouh c'est le plus gêné ricine des
cadeaux de noël de tout le temps le film
a été réalisé en finlande un pays qui se
trouve tout près de la laponie où vit le
père noël c'est un vol d'entraînement
une équipe a travaillé pendant deux ans
pour créer ce film carrie le réalisateur
les animateurs et beaucoup d'autres
personnes ont participé à la création de
nico devrait bien d'apprendre à ne pas
compter sur les autres dit qu'on moi je
n'ai besoin de personne pour veiller sur
moi ou si tu ne sais pas prendre soin de
toi tu n'atteindra jamais moulage
tout d'abord ils ont écrit l'histoire
cela s'appelle un scénario puis ils ont
fait le storyboard l'histoire mais en
dessin ils ont imaginé puis dessiner
tous les personnages
nico je nie julius et tous les autres ma
b j j cogn à moi sereine dont une cause
ça je peux dire que je de konya nico ni
connu on vient dernière entraînements le
jour
pour créer l'univers de nico ils ont
fait de longues recherches
enfin de trouver les bonnes couleurs et
de belles textures
ensuite ils ont dessiné l'ensemble des
décors à partir du story board puis ils
ont modélisé tous les dessins des
personnages et des décors sur des
ordinateurs très puissants modéliser
signifie transformer les dessins sur
papier en 3d sur l'ordinateur
il intègre les personnages dans les
décors ainsi ils peuvent les faire
évoluer et leur donner vie dans les
différentes aventures de l'histoire